you're writing to the main leaders of
the parties aren't you and challenging
them to do more on homelessness what is
it that you want to say I am I'm calling
for a much greater focus on what I would
describe as a national crisis if you go
to any English city or town at the
moment you will see people huddled in
the doorways in 2018 over 700 people who
were homeless died many of them on
British streets this shouldn't be
happening in my view in 2019 and my
frustration a little bit is British
general elections focus on swing voters
in key marginals you know so-called
Worcester woman or Workington man
how about focusing on homeless woman and
homeless man you know British politics
would regain some of its moral purpose
in my view if it spent time dealing with
the real issues that we are facing on
the ground it feels like sometimes the
election campaign happens in a parallel
universe and my purpose today is saying
look come back to a real crisis that's
happening now to be fair Jeremy Corbyn
is the only person that has spoken about
homelessness is in this campaign we need
to hear detailed proposals from all of
the three main parties I just want to
look at your record at tackling
homelessness in Manchester as well and
because there was an investigation by
the Manchester Evening News recently
that said that Manchester is putting 411
percent more homeless families into
temporary accommodation compared to 2015
six everyday and at last month alone
1,700 people went to the town hall
either because they were homeless or
they were worried about becoming
homeless so if you actually got a grip
on the situation yourself well this this
goes to the heart of what I'm saying
today Sophie because I can't control
those numbers that are presenting us
homeless to the council that's because
in my view mainly the benefits freeze so
there's been a housing allowance freeze
in benefits since 2016 so people's
benefits have not been keeping pace with
their rent and that is a national issue
I can't do anything about that
what I can do is obviously try and help
people who find themselves in that
situation so my commitment is around
rough sleeping rather than the bigger
question of homelessness and what we
have done here is create places for
people
to go every night of the week in great
monster tonight there will be around 400
bed spaces across Artem burrows no other
part of the country is doing this we
recorded the first fall in the numbers
of people sleeping rough last year after
seven years of pretty massive Rises so
I'm not saying but by any means that
we've cracked it here but we are doing
everything we can to look after people
but we won't be able to do it unless
there are real changes in national
policy on the benefits freeze that has
to come to an end immediately day one of
a new government but I would also say
this question of no-fault evictions
where private landlords can basically
evict people after eight weeks without
any real reason that that too is a
massive cause of homelessness in Greater
Manchester
I want the general election campaign to
focus on these specifics because
homelessness is a national crisis it's a
humanitarian crisis nobody should be
dying on British streets in 2019
okay now labour is finalizing its
manifesto today's big meeting to try and
get everyone together to work out what
should go in the manifesto and one of
the things that could be debated later
is whether or not labour would back
continuing free movement of people from
the EU if brexit actually happens and we
know of course there are different
opinions on this from within the party
you've spoken out before on immigration
or free movement looking at a piece that
you wrote for the Guardian in 2016 for
example you said that we can all debate
what the referendum vote meant beyond
the decision to leave the EU but above
all I am clear it was a majority vote
for an end to the current system free
movement so given that you think that
was the message of the referendum do you
think that Labour should back continued
free movement after perhaps then
I think the party needs to do a sensible
deal with Europe that would allow change
to the way we manage migration I've
always said that and one of the reasons
I think people voted in the way that
they did was a sense of unfairness
between the way people come from Europe
retreated but people from India or
Pakistan or other countries get a
differential treatment so I think this
is an opportunity to get fairness into
the immigration systems that it deals
with people on the same level wherever
they they come from and and I do believe
that the public we're asking for a
reform of that kind but I think what
labor is also right to be talking about
is doing a deal that keeps us as close
to Europe as possible and I think
they've got the only sensible position
on brexit in this election campaign
because they are trying to bring the
country back together
I think the Tories on the other hand
have got a very hard brexit position I
think the Lib Dems actually got a very
arrogant position just to say well
revoke it all as if the referendum never
happened I honestly I can't see how that
position can do anything other than
inflame that the divisions that we have
in our country so to be fair I think the
Labour Party are wrestling with this
issue they are trying to bring the
country back together it's a difficult
one of course because there are still
different perspectives within the labour
party but I think they're right to be
talking about a practical deal that
keeps us as close to Europe as possible
and that I would say is a very good
position in contrast to the other
parties so just to be crystal clear then
listening to what you're saying do you
think that it's important that Labour
should back a position where free
movement of people ends after brexit I
think the public voted for change in the
way the immigration arrangements work
with Europe to deny that I think would
be to deny what many people were saying
when they went to vote in 2016 and
that's just in my view a fact and it
doesn't help politicians it doesn't help
Parliament's if they look like they're
kind of cocooned away from that that
public view but I think what we
shouldn't do is sort of introduce
wholesale change you know just just some
greater management of the system I
expressed a lot when I was the MP for Li
hao
movement had allowed in my view the
undercutting of wages some people debate
this but I saw evidence of it where
people were were brought in by agencies
from from other European countries and
it was used to to bring wages down now
you know those are the issues that need
to be addressed and it was good to hear
Laura pitcock this week talking about
much more sectoral bargaining to protect
the wages of skilled workers because I
think that is one of the reforms that we
need to see and that is a change the way
free movement obviously has worked okay
and of course in this election campaign
as in every election campaign you see a
politicians hitting the bat of buses
getting on planes trains visiting
different parts of the country and do
you think there's been enough of a focus
from all of the parties there on issues
that aren't going to be particularly
impacting the people that you represent
in the north of England no you know I I
gathered at the start of this campaign
you know that the number-10 spin doctors
were saying that they wanted Boris
Johnson so connected with the north all
he certainly connected with the voters
of South Yorkshire this week and I think
this kind of shows that the kind of
superficial nature of the Westminster
kind of operation you know you think
they can just wander in and sort of do a
photo op but it's not like that you know
there was a national kind of emergency
developing last weekend and you know no
one's focus was on that and those poor
people in South Yorkshire would just
look left to what they were what they
were doing so what I'm doing today as
well with homelessness is hang on a
minute you know we don't want a general
election campaign that is just focusing
on kind of sound bites and kind of
issues that kind of appeal to the the
Westminster bubble
how about grappling with the very real
issues that people are facing take
railways Sophie there were terrible
scenes at Manchester Victoria the other
night we've had 18 months of chaos on
our railways and actually it even
predates that but where where is the
debate about that in this general
election campaign it's as if the kind of
voters are living through quite tough
times on the railways the issues with
homelessness and the election campaign
sometimes feels as though it's happening
in a in a
parallel universe and if they're going
to properly connect with the voters of
the north they have to say what are they
going to do about the northern franchise
what are they going to do about
investing in infrastructure are they
going to give us London style subsidies
to run our buses and are they going to
give councils help to deal with the
homelessness crisis you know these are
the things that they need to address and
as far as I'm concerned the election
campaign hasn't got close to them at the
moment and just very briefly you
mentioned working to the man bit earlier
in the interview apparently he's the
voter who's gonna decide the election
white man in his forties voted leave
didn't go to university worried about
crime do you listen to this never think
it's a bit reductive it's a bit
patronizing oh you're not kidding and in
some ways it was kind of a complete
frustration with all of that that made
me in the end sort of step away from
Westminster III think the system needs
massive reform you know as I said this
superficial approach to politics just
focusing on key marginals and swing
voters within those places it needs to
get back to a sense of a moral purpose
for the whole of the country and you
know deal with some of these major
issues that we've we're facing you know
I look at things from my perspective now
and I see the pressure on our councils
the pressure on Social Care you know
we've all been promised solutions on
Social Care again it would appear to
only be labor that is making a very
determined pledge on that you know what
where is the debate on those issues in
this election campaign and my fear is as
it stands at the moment Sophie this
election may solve nothing and we may be
back in a dysfunctional Parliament in a
few months time with the rest of us in
the real world dealing with things that
they are kind of completely neglecting
and British politics needs fundamental
reform in my view and actually there are
some green shoots coming through here
and it's called devolution in places
like Greater Manchester Westminster
can't be the only show in town anymore
because it's not dealing with things
give more power out to the English
regions to cities like like Manchester
let us do more for ourselves because you
know what you'll find that there's a
healthier politics when you do things in
that way when you when you give people
more power over their own affairs